اشعلت حروبنا واحمدت اخرى الساحره
المستديره تاثيرها ساحر كسمها رسميا شدد
ويشدد الجميع على اهميته عدم تدخل السياسه
بالرياضه واقرا التاريخ يشير لعكس ذلك
ودعونا نعود بالزمن العام
1930 اول كاس عالم في التاريخ ونعم العبوا
ان يسمى الاستقلال في فيديو والحدث نهائي
المونديال الارجنتين ضد المضيف اوروغواي
والاخيره كانت تحتفل بمروري مئه عام على
الاستقلال ومن الارجنتين
في النسختين التاليتين
و2938 قدم مصري الايطالي على انه انتصار
للفشيه على الايديولوجيات الاخرى ارتدى
اللاعبون زي الاسود كرمزا لدعمهم للحزب
الفاشي وواضبوا على اداء التحيه الفاشيه
قبل المباريات وهذا امر استفاده منه هتلر
لاحقا هذا
في بدايه الثلاثينات ليستضيف الالعاب
الاولمبيه
ولكنها زعيمه رايحه ثالثه لم يكن له شيدا
هذا الملعب بضخمته لاسباب ناريه
تفوق العرق وتفوق المانيا النازيه
اصلا هام في الثوره الجزائريه التي انطلقت
عام
1954 كتبه لاعبوا كره القدم ذهبوا من
فرنسا الى تونس وشكلوا فريق جبهه التحرير
الوطنيه لينطلقوا في جوله عالميه كبرى عام
يعرف الجميع في كره القدم مصطلحات حرب
مجازيا بالطبع ويدل على شده التنافس لكن
نحن الان في العمل
الحرب كانت مصطلحا واقعيا حرب المئه ساعه
بين دولتين السلفادور وهندورس
للكراره ضحيتها اكثر من ثلاثه الاف
نمرو بالزمن مشاهدينا وصولا الى
1986 مونديال المكسيكا التواجهت انجلترا
مع الارجنتين الارجنتين انتصرت وسجل
اسطرتها مارادونا هدفين لكن ما علاقه ذلك
بالسياسه بريطانيا والارجنتين كانتا في
حرب الفوكلاند التي اندلعت قبلها باربع
سنوات وخرج مارادونا بعد المباراه
بتصريحات تربط الرياضه بالسياسه
[موسيقى]
كريم
رئاسي على اخر في فرنسا زين الدين زيدان
الشخص الاكثر شعبيه في فرنسا وكان ذلك
الذي حصل لها مونديال
1998 حتى ان خاف على تصويت ضد جيم ماري
لوبان 2002 وبنته في 2000 وسبعه عشر وهو
امر يحاول الرئيس الفرنسي الان امن
والمكرونت ايضا
تقعد كده
الامم المتحده وايضا الجيش الفرنسيه
كلاسيكو